the size of the chip and the IMAX in the  area 65 IMAX cameras is spectacular the  amount of information that can all look  the resolution at which you can hold it  at and the image truly is beautiful I'm  not sure how much better we can continue  to make images look beyond that camera  you know I would say also with this  camera you know Joe and I like a very  active camera so the development of a  digital camera like the area 65 IMAX was  essential for us to be able to use and  execute a lot of the camera moves we  like to do the scale of this movie the  amount of characters the settings you  know are so fantastical a good level of  execution is so big that it really again  just requires that aspect ratio people  who go see in an IMAX they're gonna be  blown away  [Music]  you